yeah we filmed something for a project
yeah the tone of the day was to face
some fears you know first i got to talk
about this snake it was a five foot six
rattlesnake the snake comes out of the
of the gatorade tub
and this dude is having a time
trying to get it to [ __ ] chill out
and meanwhile its tail is going
but he he milks the snake
i i held its tail it was pretty gross
yeah the venom was i don't know it was
like a quarter shot of alcohol and he's
like yeah this could kill six people you
know then it was time for us to do the
dares
i put like some hissing cockroaches on
my face and then we did a tarantula and
they put it on my crotch i just didn't
care at that point
so the big hero moment
when you got to set
yeah that someone mentioned it to me
okay i was like i don't know why you
guys are pranking me this is what are we
doing though like what's going on yeah
and everyone's kind of like got like
sort of a wry smile on set and they're
like oh just wait and so
we meet up with this woman she's like
you know
ranch lady she's wearing like jeans and
a hat and she's like come on boys like
let's get dirty or something like that
and yeah so we're like okay we walk up
and there's a cow
like tied up to a into a railing and
she's holding
a big bottle she's also holding
these giant gloves that are
the length of an arm
plastic gloves right yeah and so she
puts one of these things on and she's
like all right lube me up
and i was like what do you mean this is
lube
why do you need this much lube and she's
like just dump a whole bunch of lube in
my hand and so i was like okay and i
poured a bunch of lube like she's like
more more lube and this thing like by
this you know by this point this this
this fist is lubed up yeah no it's it's
literally a chalice of lube yeah
in her hand yeah and so she then makes
this shape
and pulls the cow's tail up and just
dives directly into this thing's [ __ ]
right she's up to her wrists right now
in this cow's body
and then
and then we're looking at each other
like oh my god oh my god and then she
just goes all the way and just pushes
her arm her entire arm all the way
inside this cow up to her [ __ ]
shoulder and i have to note that the
whole time she's doing this the cow
keeps like shifting and moving and she's
like oh easy easy easy yeah and she's
just moving with it yeah they're just
now they're the human centipede yeah so
she's now she's armed she's shoulder
deep in this thing and she's describing
like the medical benefits of doing this
procedure or like the reason why you'd
even do it in the first place it's like
feel like the
pregnant
um
her uterus basically when she's pregnant
or you like can feel all their organs
and [ __ ] i guess yeah and so it's to
like keep track of the cow make sure
it's healthy when it's pregnant and so
on and so forth she's just talking to us
about its organs she's like you can feel
everything it's really amazing i'm like
that's great
she's she's armed deep in this
cow ass so after the lady gives us this
beautiful speech about internal organs
she unsleeves her hand from the [ __ ]
and it is
covered in cow [ __ ]
it is
covered in calcium i cannot explain to
you how gross that moment was
i don't think you need to explain an arm
covered in cow [ __ ]
liquid cow [ __ ]
dude and this is [ __ ] both this is [ __ ]
deep in the colon this is like [ __ ]
before it actually forms and becomes
solid it's just like green
i can remember hold that [ __ ]
dude she pulled that [ __ ] out
and i looked i took one look at her arm
and took one little smell like that
i went like this oh
and i'm standing there like literally
for five minutes
on the verge of puking shut the [ __ ] up
so that that is actually the important
distinction oh wait
and you're forgetting you're forgetting
what she did after her arm came what
does she do
she [ __ ] turns to me yeah she [ __ ]
pulls her arm out
now she's cupping oh i got a handful of
[ __ ]
she's cuffing a handful of [ __ ] she
turns to me and gestures a handful of
[ __ ] to me and goes
you're gonna get a little poop on your
hands
[Laughter]
i'm seriously thinking about this
actually it's just sitting back every so
now me and cody are dry heaving
like
you know whatever so then fast forward
you know
after seeing all that i still put the
glove on you know cody's now he's like
put the lube in your hand put the lube
in your hand and he just he dumps it
into my hand trying to egg me on i lubed
my boy up
so
so then
she like preps my glove
i get next to the cow
she pulls up the tail my hand
is like on that and mind you
the [ __ ] is green
so i'm about to go in
and then i and i and i back out of my
whoa
i turn away and i go oh it's just like
reaching in a can of pesto all right i
can do this
i go back up to the [ __ ]
and i made it you looked at it i made
the mistake because like i'm thinking
like this is like this is like a moment
of bravery so i'm gonna look
this monster in the eyes i look at the
[ __ ] this [ __ ] looked like meat
canyon drew it yeah yeah yeah it is it
was so gigantic and just like it was
like a human's [ __ ] just exaggerated
times 5 000. oh yeah no it looked like
the eye of sauron made of ham it was
[ __ ] gross dude
so i was like i'm brave if i look at it
right
and my bravery so quickly disappeared
i'm like what am i doing i had a like an
instant existential crisis i'm like what
is the meaning of life that i'm like
what am i doing i didn't sign up for
this and i like woke up this morning i'm
not going to go armed deep in a cow ass
like just cuz like
so i bailed i'm like nah
but you know we're rolling and for
whatever reason i don't know what
possessed you well because i'm like i
there's no other way out there's no
other way out of this
there isn't we're standing there with
the girl who just taught us how to do
this she's looking at us like you know
like come on [ __ ]
and oh yeah she's saying they're
standing there like
you don't have to but like you know and
the cow's [ __ ] is like come on yeah
yeah it is you know insert
inside go inside me insert yourself so i
was like all right [ __ ] it put the glove
on what's hilarious is the whole time
the lady is like barking at me
she's like come on be a man who's going
to be a man
i'm like clearly you're the man in this
situation
like very you're the man like obviously
you're the the man here yeah yeah so
cody
lubed up
made the alligator but she didn't look
at the [ __ ] uh no no i didn't i
looked away
i i got the general like gist of where i
was and then i kind of looked away and
like i kind of felt it i found it with
you know with touch
yeah and i go in and it's like you know
you you kind of get in there it's like
difficult up to the wrist yeah and then
it just slides
i mean it seemed that way once you got
past the hard point you just like you're
just locked into that yeah you wore her
like a glove man yeah
yeah that was just you now she it took
some encouragement though from the lady
she was like nah all the way up to the
shoulder and i was like i'm in i did it
i can i leave now and i'm like no you
got to go all the way and then like the
they're running around the camera's like
dude's reaction get his reaction and i'm
so glad i didn't do this because now
with you shoulder deep into the cow
you're like drooling from like dry
heaving i was yes i was fully salivating
and drooling it's like you were just
like
i was also like blacked out
i blacked out for a second because i was
like i don't remember this
but what i did remember was feeling her
uterus oh it was [ __ ] crazy literally
you could feel like her organs
yeah
and all that it just felt like you know
halloween like when they put in a
haunted house they like tell you to put
your
hand into a bowl of like wet spaghetti
or something like that yeah
it was like that but it was a lot
smoother you're doing all that and that
cow is like on the other side like oh my
god oh my god who is this
oh yeah what the [ __ ] he is in my guts
oh my god
he's literally mixing my [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god
i knew i didn't have any walls
jesus and she's just up there rolling
her eyes just ah
and you're just he's three feet long oh
my god
yeah and you're shoulder deep and then
it comes out you pull the glove as i'm
as i'm coming out she goes grab some
[ __ ] on the way out
literally as yes as i'm at the point
where i can feel it clumping up in my
head
it's like collecting there oh just
without i'm sorry i'm sorry but it's
like literally i just have to i have to
like illustrate how gross this was
because as she said that it was like
involuntarily collecting in my hand
anyways
and so i felt it it just made it so much
more real the fact that she said collect
some [ __ ] as it's collecting in my hand
and then i pull it out it's like
[Music]
and then uh
and then it was on my shirt
[Music]
and this is actually the shirt yeah so
that i was wearing i haven't watched it
yet no you're forgetting the best part
we we go to change
and you're like touching your face
i'm like dude did you wash your hands
you're like oh yeah i should probably do
that i'm like yeah you should definitely
do that
did you just
we were we're joking on set about it
it like being quicksand in there or
something like that yeah yeah
like i get all the way in and i'm like
i'm in i'm in guys it's not stopping
guys it's not stuck guys just slowly
yeah and then you just see my two feet
like
the whole thing just like just swallow
my entire body augustus gloop man yeah
exactly
guys it's not and everyone's like
laughing on set and like vomiting and
they're all laughing this is so so great
and i'm like
[ __ ] up
oh my god dude
what a what a time
you